we built this new compiler framework
called mlar
yes mlr is this a whole new framework
it's not
many people think it's about machine
learning the ml stands for multi-level
because
compiler people can't name things very
well i guess can we dig into what
ml ir is yeah so when you look at
compilers compilers have historically
been solutions for a given space
so lvm is a it's really good for dealing
with cpus
let's just say at a high level you look
at java
java has a jvm the jvm is very good for
garbage collected languages that need
dynamic compilation and it's
very optimized for specific space and so
hotspot is one of the compilers that
gets used in that space and that
compiler is really good at that kind of
stuff
um usually when you build these domain
specific compilers
you end up building the whole thing from
scratch for each domain
uh what's the domain so what what what's
this
what's the scope of a domain well so
here i would say like
if you look at swift there's several
different parts to the swift compiler
um one of which is covered by um the lvm
part of it
there's also a high-level piece that's
specific to swift
and there's a huge amount of redundancy
between those
two different infrastructures and a lot
of re-implemented stuff that is
similar but different what does llvm
define lvm
is effectively an infrastructure so you
can
mix and match it in different ways it's
built out of libraries you can use it
for different things
but it's really good at cpus and gpus
cpus and like the tip of the iceberg on
gpus it's not really great at gpus
okay um but it turns out the languages
that
then use it to talk to cpus got it
and so it turns out there's a lot of
hardware out there that is custom
accelerators so machine learning for
example
there are a lot of uh matrix multiply
accelerators and things like this
there there's a whole world of hardware
synthesis so
we're using mlar to build circuits
okay and so you're compiling for a
domain of transistors
and so what mlr does is it provides a
tremendous amount of compiler
infrastructure that allows you to build
these
domain specific compilers in a much
faster way and
have the result be good if we're if
we're thinking about the future
now we're talking about like asics so
anything yeah yeah so
if we project into the future it's very
possible that
the number of these kinds of asics very
specific uh infrastructure
thing the architecture things uh
like multiplies exponentially i hope so
yeah
so that's mlir so what mlr
what mlr does is allows you to build
these compilers very efficiently
right now one of the things that coming
back to the lvm thing and then we'll go
to hardware
is um lvm is a is a specific compiler
for specific domain
mlr is now this very general very
flexible thing that can solve
lots of different kinds of problems so
lvm is a subset of what mlr does
so mri is i mean it's an ambitious
project then yeah it's a very ambitious
project yeah and so
to make it even more confusing mlr has
joined the llvm umbrella project so it's
part of the lvm family
right but where this comes full circle
is now folks that work on the lvm
part the classic part that's 20 years
old aren't
aware of all the cool new things that
have been done in the new the new thing
that you know mlr was built by me and
many other people that
knew a lot about llvm and so we fixed a
lot of the mistakes that lived in
lvm i mean now you have this community
dynamic where it's like well there's
this new thing but it's not familiar
nobody knows it it feels like it's new
and so
let's not trust it and so it's just
really interesting to see the cultural
social
dynamic that comes out of that and and
you know i think it's super healthy
because we're seeing the ideas percolate
and we're seeing the technology
diffusion happen
as people get more comfortable with it
they start to understand things in their
own terms and
this just gets to the it takes a while
for ideas to propagate even though
um they may be very different than what
people are used to
you